I don't know when I got this idea that a captain's log be pretty interesting to read. Probably it was from watching Star Trek as a kid. You know, they do that whole captain's log star date thing. But in fact, in real life, here on planet earth, most captain's logs--
我不知道什么时候产生了这样的想法：船长日志读起来应该会很有趣。可能是我小时候看《星际迷航》受的影响。你知道，他们总是做那种“船长日志，星历日期”之类的记录。但实际上，在现实生活中，在地球上，大多数船长日志——
Usually they're incredibly boring. I mean, it's like, you know, it's really primarily meant to be a record of ships' positions, weather.
通常都无聊透顶。我的意思是，这基本上就是为了记录船只的位置和天气。
That's the story on Erik Larson. He ran into this when he was writing a book about this hurricane that destroyed the city of Galveston in 1900. He thought that ships at sea might have interesting observations about the formation of this historic weather event, this storm. So he looked at lots of ships' logs.
埃里克·拉尔森（Erik Larson）就是这么发现的。他在写一本关于1900年摧毁加尔维斯顿市飓风的书时遇到了这种情况。他原以为海上的船只可能会对这场历史性天气事件——这场风暴的形成有有趣的观察记录。所以他查阅了大量的航海日志。
And I found it very frustrating, very frustrating. It was just, like, routine references. And meanwhile, here's this gigantic storm looming on the horizon.
我发现这非常令人沮丧，真的非常令人沮丧。里面全是些例行公事的记载。而与此同时，一场巨大的风暴正在地平线上酝酿。
And why? What would they way in their logs?
为什么会这样？他们在日志里会写什么呢？
Nothing. They would just list, you know, some wind speed, wind direction. Sometimes I think that a ship could be passing Krakatoa when it was blowing up, and there would be no reference, except maybe a sudden change in the air temperature.
什么都不写。他们只是列出风速、风向。有时候我觉得，哪怕一艘船经过正在喷发的喀拉喀托火山，日志里也不会有任何提及，顶多可能提到气温的突然变化。
A ship's log does record anything unusual that happens on the ship itself, any damage to the ship. But really, it's about legal and administrative responsibilities. If cargo's damaged, insurers are going to need a record, that kind of thing.
航海日志确实会记录船上发生的任何异常情况，或是船只的任何损坏。但实际上，它主要关乎法律和行政责任。如果货物损坏了，保险公司会需要一份记录，诸如此类。
Which is why this one captain's log that Larson found really stood out. He was researching the sinking of the Lusitania for his book, Dead Wake . And he got his hands on the captain's log for the U-boat that sunk the Lusitania in 1915.
正因如此，拉尔森发现的一份船长日志才显得格外突出。当时他正在为自己的书《死寂》（Dead Wake）研究卢西塔尼亚号的沉没。他搞到了1915年击沉卢西塔尼亚号的那艘U型潜艇的船长日志。
The prose is businesslike and direct, just like most logs, even in translation from the German. But this captain just includes way more stuff, like way more detail than other logs that Larson had read. When Captain Walter Schwieger spots the Lusitania at 2:20 submarine time, he notes four funnels and two masts.
文字简洁干练，就像大多数日志一样，即使是翻译成德语也是如此。但这位船长包含的信息量要多得多，比拉尔森读过的其他日志详细得多。当沃尔特·施威格（Walter Schwieger）船长在潜艇时间2:20发现卢西塔尼亚号时，他记录下了四个烟囱和两根桅杆。
You know, starboard ahead, coming from south to southwest, it's steered towards Galley Head, which is a Maritime landmark there in the Irish sea. The ship is made out to be a large passenger steamer. Then he says submerged to a depth of 11 meters, and at full speed, took a course converging.
“右舷前方，从南向西南方向驶来，正朝着加利角（Galley Head）航行，”那是爱尔兰海的一处海上地标。“该船看来是一艘大型客轮。”然后他说，“下潜至11米深度，全速前进，取汇合航向。”
So, so far, very matter of fact.
到目前为止，非常客观冷静。
Very matter of fact. Now, what's important to know here as well is that, meanwhile, what's happening aboard his submarine is total chaos. He's doing a fast dive, which, depending on conditions, sometimes involved having members of the crew race to the bow, run to the front of the submarine to add ballast.
非常冷静。现在，这里同样重要的一点是，与此同时，他的潜艇里正处于完全的混乱之中。他正在进行紧急下潜，根据当时的情况，有时需要船员们冲向船头，跑到潜艇前端增加配重。
To add that extra weight.
增加额外的重量。
Yes. So he's doing this very fast dive. There's chaos aboard the submarine. There's a lot of energy, a lot of excitement.
是的。所以他正在进行这种快速下潜。潜艇内一片混乱，充满紧张感和躁动。
That human drama doesn't make it into the log, even this one. 2:35 PM submarine time, the ship that he's chasing turns starboard towards a town called Queenstown. He runs at the ship at high speed, which Larson says was actually not very fast at all. 3:10 PM submarine time, the log says he takes a clean bow shot at a distance of 700 meters. He names the kind of torpedo he uses and the depth adjustment he makes, the angle.
那种人性化的戏剧冲突并没有被写进日志，即使是这一份也没有。潜艇时间下午2:35，他正在追击的船转向右舷，驶向一个叫昆斯敦（Queenstown）的城镇。他以高速冲向那艘船，拉尔森说这其实一点也不快。潜艇时间下午3:10，日志上写着他在700米的距离上进行了一次干净利落的船头射击。他写明了他使用的鱼雷种类、深度调整，以及角度。
"Torpedo hits starboard side right behind the bridge." There it is. That's the actual firing of the torpedo in the attack. Then, though, he starts in with a fairly elaborate-- at least for a German submarine commander-- narrative.
“鱼雷击中右舷，就在舰桥后方。”就是这样。这就是攻击中鱼雷实际发射的时刻。不过，随后他开始写下一段相当详尽的——至少对于一名德国潜艇指挥官来说——叙述。
He's watching this now through his periscope. "An usually strong explosion or detonation takes place with a very strong explosive cloud. The cloud reaches far beyond the front funnel. The explosion of the torpedo must have been accompanied by a second one," parentheses, "boiler or coal or powder?" Question mark.
他现在正通过潜望镜观察这一切。“发生了一次异常强烈的爆炸或引爆，伴有非常浓烈的爆炸烟云。烟云延伸到前烟囱之外。鱼雷的爆炸一定伴随着第二次爆炸，”括号，“锅炉、煤炭还是火药？”问号。
"The superstructure right above the point of the impact and the bridge are torn asunder. Fire breaks out, and the smoke envelops the high bridge. The ship stops." He's incorrect there, by the way. The ship continued at 18 knots because its engines were knocked out, and you need engines in order to stop a ship.
“冲击点正上方的上层建筑和舰桥被炸得粉碎。火灾爆发，浓烟笼罩了高大的舰桥。船停下了。”顺便说一句，他这里错了。船依然以18节的速度航行，因为它的引擎被摧毁了，而让一艘船停下需要引擎。
"The ship stops immediately and heels over to starboard very quickly." And he says, "immersing simultaneously at the bowel. Great confusion ensues on board. The boats are made clear, and some of them are lowered to the water."
“船立即停止，并迅速向右舷倾斜。”他还说，“同时船头下沉。船上一片大乱。救生艇被清理出来，其中一些被放下水面。”
He means the lifeboats there.
他指的是那里的救生艇。
Yes, the lifeboats. "In doing so, some must have lost their heads. Some boats, full to the capacity, are lowered, touch the water with either stem or stern first, and founder immediately."
是的，救生艇。“在放下过程中，有些人一定乱了阵脚。一些满载的救生艇被放下去时，船头或船尾先触水，随即倾覆。”
This is actually happening as they're filling with water, capsizing, sinking. It is a grisly scene-- people throwing themselves off the ship into the water and getting sucked underneath the sinking vessel, people getting crushed by the lifeboats. 1,198 died.
这实际上是发生在它们进水、倾覆、下沉的过程中。这是一幕可怕的场景——人们从船上跳入水中，被卷入下沉船只的下方，有人被救生艇挤压。1198人死亡。
Captain Schwieger watches through his periscope, and he can't actually hear anything. What he's seeing is like this terrible silent movie. 3:25 PM submarine time in the log.
施威格船长通过潜望镜观察，他实际上听不到任何声音。他所看到的就像是一部可怕的无声电影。日志时间为潜艇时间下午3:25。
"As it seems as if the steamer will keep above water only a short time, we dived to a depth of 24 meters and ran out to sea." Now, what he means there is he doesn't have to hang around and fire another torpedo.
“由于这艘轮船看起来只能在水面上停留很短时间，我们下潜到24米的深度并驶向公海。”他这里的意思是，他不必逗留再去发射第二枚鱼雷了。
However, here he says the most controversial statement in is log. "It would have been impossible for me anyhow to fire a second torpedo into this crushing crowd of humanity trying to save their lives."
然而，他在日志里说了最有争议的一句话。“无论如何，我都不可能向这群拼命挣扎的挤作一团的人群发射第二枚鱼雷。”
"It would have been impossible for me to fire a second torpedo into this crushing crowd of humanity trying to save their lives." This sentence is controversial because he's never like this anywhere else in the log, never sympathetic to his enemies this way. He never expresses feelings like this in this log that's going to be read, you know, by his superior officers. Why say this?
“我不可能向这群拼命挣扎的挤作一团的人群发射第二枚鱼雷。”这句话之所以有争议，是因为他在日志的其他任何地方都没有这样过，从未对他的敌人表现出这种同情。在这份即将被他的上级军官阅读的日志中，他从未表达过这样的感受。为什么要这么说？
I don't know what to think. I would like to think that this captain had that level of remorse, right, and that he acknowledged it right there at the time. I don't think so. My money is on a post-patrol revision that he may have added that after the fact, after everybody recognized how much the world had been repulsed by this attack on men, women, and children on an unarmed passenger ship.
我不知道该怎么想。我愿意相信这位船长当时确实有这种悔意，并且他在那时就承认了。但我认为并非如此。我敢打赌这是巡逻后的修订，他可能是事后才加上去的，在全世界都对这次针对无武装客船上男女老幼的袭击感到反感之后。
But if you think about it, even this, it doesn't totally add up. Like, OK, sure, the rest of the world was horrified by the sinking of the Lusitania . But Schwieger lived in Germany, where this was celebrated, a huge victory.
但如果你仔细想想，即使是这样，也完全说不通。比如，好吧，当然，全世界都被卢西塔尼亚号的沉没震惊了。但施威格生活在德国，在那里这是一场备受赞誉的巨大胜利。
Did he want to change the log because he thought like, OK, maybe they would actually lose the war and he worried about how this was going to look? Did he just not want this to be his legacy, how he'd be talked about 100 years later as, you know, I'm doing right this second?
他想修改日志是因为他觉得，好吧，也许他们真的会输掉战争，而他担心这看起来会怎样？他只是不想让这成为他的遗产，不想让人们在100年后像我现在这样讨论他吗？
Well, today on our program, we bring you captain's logs of various sorts. For every story in today's show, we found a terse, businesslike record of some kind of some event in the past. Some of these are historic events. Some of them are small and personal. And what we're going to do is we're going to go back and reconstruct what really happened, which is way more complicated and emotional than the logs.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将为您带来各种各样的船长日志。对于今天节目中的每一个故事，我们都找到了一种简练的、公事公办的记录，记录了过去发生的某种事件。其中一些是历史事件，一些是微小而私人的。我们将要做的是，回去重建真正发生的事情，那比日志要复杂和感人得多。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, mateys.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。和我们待在一起吧，伙伴们。
Act 1, "Cookies and Monsters." So part of what's interesting about reading captain's logs is then going back and piecing together the true story that they're only sort of telling. And that is what PJ Vogt does in this next story. He starts picking something apart and asking questions, and he ends up somewhere very different from where he starts. Here's PJ.
第一幕，“饼干与怪兽”。阅读船长日志的有趣之处在于回去拼凑出他们仅仅只是粗略叙述的真实故事。这也是PJ·沃格特（PJ Vogt）在接下来的故事中所做的。他开始剖析某件事并提出问题，最终他到达了一个与起点截然不同的地方。这是PJ的故事。
I've got a friend, let's call him Dale. Dale has a Gmail address that's pretty generic, like [email protected] . And people with email addresses like these get a lot of emails that just aren't meant for them, like email wrong numbers. And this happens to him all the time.
我有个朋友，咱们叫他戴尔。戴尔有一个非常大众化的Gmail地址，比如[email protected]。拥有这类电子邮件地址的人会收到很多根本不是发给他们的邮件，就像电子邮件里的“打错电话”。这对他来说是常有的事。
Last time I saw him, he'd just gotten an email written completely in Spanish from a kid somewhere asking if he could turn in some work late. Dale's a nice guy, but he likes to play pranks. He likes to mess with people. So he answers the emails. Here's one he got a while back.
上次见到他时，他刚收到一封完全用西班牙语写的邮件，来自某处的孩子问他是否可以迟交作业。戴尔是个好人，但他喜欢搞恶作剧。他喜欢捉弄人。所以他回复了这些邮件。这是他前阵子收到的其中一封。
I think it started off, "Hey, ladies. To all Calgary area district commissioners and district cookie advisers." And then it started talking about how they had a bunch of stale cookies that they didn't know what to do with, and we've got to move them off the shelves. And if they're past the expiration date, then we can't use them in the next cookie campaign.
我想开头是这样的：“嘿，女士们。致卡尔加里地区的所有区专员和饼干顾问。”然后开始讨论他们有一堆陈饼干不知道该怎么办，我们必须把它们从货架上清理掉。如果它们过了保质期，那我们就不能在下一次饼干活动中使用它们了。
The emails continue. And Dale learns that the world of professional cookie advising, it's surprisingly bureaucratic. At the top, there's a national cookie adviser. But beneath her, there are provincial cookie advisers who report up. And then beneath them, there are district cookie advisers.
邮件还在继续。戴尔了解到，专业饼干顾问的世界出奇地官僚化。最上面有全国饼干顾问。在她下面，有向她汇报的省级饼干顾问。再下面，还有区饼干顾问。
Dale has no idea what's going on here. But he decides the best thing he could do would be to reply with an intentionally stupid email, detailing a bunch of asinine solutions to the stale cookie problem. He suggests the advisers Sharpie over the expiration dates on the packages. He suggests they eat all the stale cookies themselves.
戴尔根本不知道这里发生了什么。但他决定自己能做的最好的事情就是用一封故意装傻的邮件回复，详细列出了一堆针对陈饼干问题的愚蠢解决方案。他建议顾问们用记号笔盖掉包装上的保质期。他建议他们自己吃掉所有陈饼干。
In my mind, I was thinking, no one's going to believe this. What a stupid email to write to somebody. Who would hire a person with suggestions like these?
我在心里想，没人会相信这个。写这种邮件给别人太蠢了。谁会雇佣一个提出这种建议的人呢？
Cynthia, who's the Calgary area cookie adviser, responds to Dale's email with complete polite cheerfulness. She sends him a cookie freshness calculator to help him sort his stale cookies from his fresh cookies. So Dale responds with even stupider messages. He was trying to make it more obvious that he was just kidding.
辛西娅（Cynthia），也就是卡尔加里地区的饼干顾问，以完全礼貌和愉快的态度回复了戴尔的邮件。她发给他一个饼干新鲜度计算器，帮他把陈饼干和新鲜饼干分开。所以戴尔回复了更愚蠢的信息。他试图让对方更明显地看出他在开玩笑。
I said, "What's the status on the cookies? Yarr. Me so hungry," with a picture of Cookie Monster. And I think she responded something along lines of, "Those orders were supposed to go in a month ago. Or did I misunderstand your question?"
我说：“饼干的情况怎么样了？呀。我好饿，”并附上了一张饼干怪兽的照片。我想她回复的大意是：“那些订单应该一个月前就发出的。还是我误解了你的问题？”
Rather than clarifying, Dale asks her, why are we even in the cookie advising business? He says, his clients, they're all about chocolate bars now.
戴尔没有澄清，而是问她，我们为什么要从事饼干咨询业务？他说，他的客户现在只对巧克力棒感兴趣。
And Cynthia responded, "Chocolate bars????" Question mark, question mark, question mark, question mark. All of my other suggestions were met with, like, oh, maybe I misunderstood or something. But this one was very emphatic. It was like, "Chocolate bars?"
辛西娅回复说：“巧克力棒？？？？”四个问号。我之前所有的建议都得到了诸如“哦，也许我误解了”之类的回应。但这一条非常坚定。就像是，“巧克力棒？”
It actually seemed like Dale had maybe touched a nerve. Because after that, cookie advisor world went completely quiet. Dale was bothered by this.
这看起来戴尔可能确实触到了痛处。因为那之后，饼干顾问的世界完全安静了。戴尔对此感到困扰。
The original email he'd gotten had been meant for a woman named Debbie. What if he had gotten Debbie in trouble, or even just made her look bad?
他收到的最初那封邮件是发给一个叫黛比（Debbie）的女士的。如果他害黛比惹上了麻烦，或者甚至只是让她看起来很糟糕怎么办？
I'm a little afraid. I'd like to think that, oh, they just got it sorted out, and now it's funny, and Debbie is in on the joke-- just people trying to do their cookie job.
我有点害怕。我愿意认为，哦，她们只是把它解决了，现在这很有趣，而且黛比也参与了这个玩笑——这只是人们试图做好他们的饼干工作而已。
I reached out to the woman who'd been trying to email Debbie, Cynthia, because I wanted to find out if Dale's prank had hurt anybody.
我联系了那个试图给黛比发邮件的女士辛西娅，因为我想找出戴尔的恶作剧是否伤害了任何人。
Hello?
喂？
Hello.
喂。
Hi, Cynthia?
你好，是辛西娅吗？
Yes, it's me.
是的，是我。
Hi, it's PJ.
你好，我是PJ。
Cynthia has multiple sclerosis, and it can be hard for her to talk. So her friend, Sheila, volunteered to help out. I read them the emails.
辛西娅患有多发性硬化症，说话可能有些困难。所以她的朋友希拉（Sheila）自愿帮忙。我给她们读了那些邮件。
"And of course, the obvious solution is to eat them during our next member meeting. Please discuss with the rest of area, and I will forward your decision on to national. Thanks so much." Do you remember getting that?
“当然，显而易见的解决办法是在我们下次会员会议时把它们吃掉。请与区域内其他人讨论，我会把你们的决定转达给全国。非常感谢。”你记得收到过这个吗？
You know, I don't, but--
你知道，我不记得了，但是——
We get a lot of questions all across Alberta at Cookie Time. Often, they have suggestions that don't always fly. So we find a way to respond do them as best we can.
我们在阿尔伯塔省的“饼干时间”会收到各种各样的问题。通常，他们提出的建议并不总是行得通。所以我们会尽我们所能找到回复他们的方式。
Cynthia and Sheila explained that they were part of Girl Guides. In the US, we have Girl Scouts. Most everywhere else in the world, they call them Girl Guides.
辛西娅和希拉解释说她们是女童军（Girl Guides）的一员。在美国，我们有女童子军（Girl Scouts）。在世界上其他大多数地方，她们被称为女童军。
If you know anything about Girl Scouts, you won't be too surprised by this. But Cynthia and Sheila have a way of talking that is just unrelenting positive. It's just the Girl Guide way. That's why Cynthia was so patient with Dale. It was her job.
如果你了解女童子军，你就不会对此感到太惊讶。但辛西娅和希拉有一种说话方式，那种持续不断的积极态度。这就是女童军的方式。这就是为什么辛西娅对戴尔如此耐心。这是她的工作。
But she was also very patient with me, even as-- for reasons that I don't quite understand-- I found myself explaining to her the entire pattern of events that had led Dale to email her.
但她对我也非常耐心，即使——因为一些我不完全理解的原因——我发现自己在向她解释导致戴尔给她发邮件的整个事件过程。
I guess the email was meant for Debbie, but it went to a Dale.
我猜那封邮件是发给黛比的，但发到了戴尔那儿。
Oh. Now it's starting to make a little bit of sense.
哦。现在开始有点明白了。
This helpful sunny tone, this Girl Guide voice, is hardwired into their original mission statement, which reads, quote, "A guide smiles and sings under all difficulties," end quote. Smiling and singing under all difficulties.
这种乐于助人的阳光语调，这种女童军式的声音，被深植在她们最初的使命宣言中，上面写道，引用：“向导在任何困难下都会微笑并歌唱”，结束引用。在任何困难下微笑并歌唱。
This sounds ridiculous to me, or at least it did, until I heard a truly crazy story about this exact thing, Girl Guides smiling and singing through incredibly extreme circumstances. I first heard about it from a woman named Janie Hampton. She's kind of a Girl Guide expert. She wrote a book about them.
这对我来说听起来很荒谬，或者至少在听到一个关于此事的真正疯狂的故事之前是这样的，女童军在极其极端的情况下微笑并歌唱。我第一次从一位叫珍妮·汉普顿（Janie Hampton）的女士那里听说这件事。她算是女童军方面的专家。她写了一本关于她们的书。
Now I have to admit, when I started writing the book, I thought, you know, I'm going to make this a bit of a satire and laugh at them.
现在我必须承认，当我开始写这本书时，我想，你知道，我要把它写成某种讽刺作品，嘲笑她们。
She says laughing at Girl Guides is pretty easy, because most people think of them as not particularly cool, too sincere.
她说嘲笑女童军很容易，因为大多数人认为她们不是特别酷，太真诚了。
What we call "naff" nowadays.
也就是我们今天所说的“老土”（naff）。
What's naff?
什么是“老土”？
Sort of unfashionable, nerdy.
有点过时，书呆子气。
So Janie sets out to tease some nerds. But then she starts researching. And one day, she's deep in the Girl Guides' archive in their London headquarters, and she finds this old notebook.
所以珍妮开始想要取笑一些书呆子。但随后她开始做研究。有一天，她在伦敦总部的女童军档案馆深处，发现了一本旧笔记本。
It's small, 7" by 10". And the book's a handwritten log of nearly everything one Girl Guide troop did years ago.
它很小，7英寸乘10英寸。这本书是几年前一个女童军小队几乎所做一切的手写日志。
And it said, we did skipping, and we did knots, and we did all sorts of jolly things. And then I came across this song that they'd written. And it said, "We sang our song yesterday. And it went, 'We might have been shipped to Timbuktu. We might have been shipped to Kalamazoo. It's not repatriation, nor is it yet starvation. It's simply concentration in Chefoo." And I thought, what on earth does that mean? Concentration in Chefoo?
上面写着，我们跳绳，我们打绳结，我们做了各种各样快乐的事情。然后我偶然发现了她们写的一首歌。上面写着：“我们昨天唱了我们的歌。歌词是，‘我们可能被送到了廷巴克图。我们可能被送到了卡拉马祖。这不是遣返，也不是饥荒。这仅仅是在芝罘的集中营。’”我想，这到底是什么意思？在芝罘集中营？
Janie does not know where Chefoo is. But she's sure it's not in England, so she looks it up. Chefoo is-- was-- a place in China, a coastal city. It's a good 7,000 miles from London.
珍妮不知道芝罘在哪里。但她确定那不在英格兰，所以她查了一下。芝罘是——曾经是——中国的一个地方，一个沿海城市。距离伦敦足足7000英里。
According to the guide's logbook, the song had been written and performed by a group of Girl Guides for a concert on Christmas day, 1942. The Christmas concert, Janie discovers, was held in Chefoo, but not at a school. The Girl Guides sang their song in a concentration camp. Janie was baffled.
根据那本向导日志，这首歌是由一群女童军在1942年圣诞节的音乐会上创作并演唱的。珍妮发现，圣诞音乐会是在芝罘举行的，但不是在学校。女童军是在集中营里唱她们的歌。珍妮感到困惑。
Why would a concentration camp in China have a singing Girl Guide troop? So Janie starts digging. And she finds someone who was there, an actual witness, born in China, who ended up in the same camp as these Girl Guides, this Belgian guy.
为什么中国的集中营会有唱着歌的女童军小队？所以珍妮开始挖掘。她找到了一个当时在那里的人，一个真正的见证人，出生在中国，最终和这些女童军在同一个营地，是一个比利时人。
Leopold Pander, 74 years old.
利奥波德·潘德（Leopold Pander），74岁。
The problem is, it turns out he has absolutely no memory of his time there.
问题是，事实证明，他对自己在那里的时光完全没有记忆。
I tried to remember something, but nothing comes back to me.
我试图想起点什么，但什么也想不起来。
Nothing, except for this nightmare he used to have when he was a kid. At the time, it hadn't made sense to him. But later, he thought it must have taken place at the camp.
什么也没有，除了他小时候常做的那个噩梦。当时那对他来说毫无意义。但后来，他认为那一定是在集中营里发生的。
What was the dream that you would have?
你做的那个梦是什么样的？
Well, I'm there in the hot sun, the blue sky. It's a brown slope. It's a browned earth. And there are big stones next to myself, dirty earth and people running all over the place.
嗯，我在烈日下，蓝天。这是一个棕色的斜坡。是褐色的土地。我身边有大石头，脏土，人们四处奔跑。
Are there sounds?
有声音吗？
No sound, absolutely no sound. Somebody picks me up, and then I wake up. That's all I remember. That dream came back very often.
没有声音，绝对没有声音。有人把我抱起来，然后我就醒了。这就是我记得的一切。那个梦经常回来。
Leopold grows up. And as an adult, he wants to know about this place that he used to dream about, and so he builds a website. He invites people to write in with memories of the camp. And the story he learns is pretty crazy.
利奥波德长大了。作为一个成年人，他想了解他过去常梦见的那个地方，所以他建立了一个网站。他邀请人们写下他们对集中营的记忆。他了解到的故事非常疯狂。
Japan's latest invasion of China, which has already lasted two years, is war on a huge scale.
日本对中国的最新入侵，已经持续了两年，是一场大规模的战争。
So I did not know this, but during World War II, when Japan occupied China, they built concentration camps that were filled with American and British and other European civilians.
所以我不知道这一点，但在二战期间，当日本占领中国时，他们建立了充满美国、英国和其他欧洲平民的集中营。
Japanese put their prisoners of war to work.
日本人强迫他们的战俘劳动。
Civilians who had been living in China. One of those camps was called Weihsien. That was Leopold's camp.
当时住在中国境内的平民。其中一个集中营叫潍县。那是利奥波德所在的营地。
And among the inmates at Weihsien were a group of children. They were American and British. They were mostly the kids of missionaries. And they'd been studying at a boarding school called Chefoo. Japanese troops invaded Chefoo and captured the kids and eventually brought them to Weihsien.
在潍县的囚犯中有一群孩子。他们是美国人和英国人。他们大多是传教士的孩子。他们曾在芝罘的一所寄宿学校学习。日军入侵芝罘，俘虏了这些孩子，最终把他们带到了潍县。
With their teachers, but no parents. So about 150 children who, for four years, were in this camp, and the teachers had very sensibly taken with them books, paper, musical instruments.
和老师在一起，但没有父母。所以大约有150名孩子在营地里待了四年，老师们非常有远见地带上了书籍、纸张和乐器。
And of course, one more thing.
当然，还有一件事。
Brownie uniforms, guide uniforms, all the things they thought, we're going to need this sort of thing to keep the kids occupied.
布朗尼制服，向导制服，所有他们认为我们可能会需要这些东西来让孩子们保持忙碌的东西。
In the Japanese camps, there was very little food. Prisoners died of starvation. In Weihsien, imprisoned monks would smuggle in eggs, and then everybody would share them. And then they'd also have the kids eat the ground up egg shells just to get some extra calcium.
在日本人的集中营里，食物极少。囚犯死于饥饿。在潍县，被关押的僧侣会偷运鸡蛋进来，然后大家分享。他们还会让孩子们吃磨碎的蛋壳，只是为了获取额外的钙。
The log book Janie had found was the record kept by one of the Girl Guides' leaders. The leaders were called Brown Owls. This one was a woman in her 20s. And the tone of her writing was the exact same, cheerful, impervious to bad news tone that Dale's cookie adviser email thread had had.
珍妮发现的那本日志是其中一位女童军领袖保存的记录。领袖们被称为“猫头鹰”。这一位是一位20多岁的女性。她写作的语调和戴尔饼干顾问邮件串中那种快乐、对坏消息无动于衷的语调一模一样。
This is the entry from the day they were marched into the camp. "Hello. What's this? Behind bars. Yes. It's Weihsien camp. Well, I guess there's a good deal of fun to be got out of this. Just the place to earn some badges."
这是她们被强行带进营地那一天的记录。“你好。这是什么？铁窗后面。是的。这是潍县集中营。好吧，我想这里能找到不少乐趣。正好可以赚几个勋章。”
According to the logbook, the Brown Owl ran the troop as if it were any other Girl Guide unit, concentration camp or not.
根据日志，猫头鹰把小队管理得就像任何其他女童军单位一样，不管是不是在集中营。
They were all told it doesn't matter how disgusting the food is, we still want good table manners. It doesn't matter how hungry you are, you're not going to steal. You're still going to do a good deed every day and help other people.
她们被告知，无论食物多么恶心，我们仍然需要良好的餐桌礼仪。无论你有多饿，你都不能偷窃。你仍然要做每天做一件好事，帮助他人。
Obviously the grim sadness of life in a concentration camp should have overpowered this miniature world that the Brown Owls were trying to build for their young girls. But according to Janie, that's not what happened.
显然，集中营生活的严峻悲伤本应压倒猫头鹰试图为她们的年轻女孩建立的这个微型世界。但根据珍妮的说法，事情并没有那样发生。
Instead, it was the Girl Guides who started to exert an influence on the adults around them. They lead by example.
相反，正是女童军开始对周围的成年人产生影响。她们以身作则。
It made a difference to all the adults in this camp and kept them going. The whole atmosphere was better because they had this very strong promise that they wouldn't stop smiling. They wouldn't give up. They would carry on singing songs. They would insist on everybody washing.
这对营地里的所有成年人产生了影响，并让他们坚持下去。整个气氛变得更好，因为她们有一个非常坚定的承诺，她们不会停止微笑。她们不会放弃。她们会继续唱着歌。她们会坚持让每个人都洗漱。
This is the point where I wondered, was this true? I didn't think that anybody was necessarily lying to me. I just thought probably the Brown Owl had left the bad stuff out of her log book. I figured she'd put the best possible spin on an awful situation. That's what Girl Guides do, right?
这是我感到怀疑的地方，这是真的吗？我不认为有人一定在对我撒谎。我只是觉得猫头鹰可能把坏的事情从她的日志里去掉了。我以为她是在为一个可怕的处境赋予最好的意义。女童军就是这样做的，对吧？
Oh, the door's open.
哦，门开着。
Oh, hello.
哦，你好。
Come on in.
进来吧。
Fortunately, there's a woman who's still alive and remembers Weihsien. Her name is Mary Previte. She lives in New Jersey. I visit her with my producer, Phia Bennin.
幸运的是，有一位女性还活着并记得潍县。她的名字叫玛丽·普雷维特（Mary Previte）。她住在新泽西州。我和我的制作人菲亚·贝宁（Phia Bennin）去拜访了她。
What can I tell you? Oh, by the way, can I pour you some tea? I am so bad about this. I get so busy talking that--
我能告诉你什么呢？哦，对了，能给你们倒杯茶吗？我这方面真是太糟糕了。我谈得太投入以至于——
Mary Previte is a small, beautiful 82-year-old woman. She's also one of the happiest people I've ever met. I don't know if anybody I've interviewed has ever fully broken into song unprompted. Mary did-- seven times.
玛丽·普雷维特是一位娇小、美丽的82岁老太太。她也是我见过的最快乐的人之一。我不知道我采访过的人中是否有人曾主动开口唱歌。玛丽做到了——七次。
Also, unlike Leopold, Mary has a phenomenal memory. She told me about the day that Japanese troops arrived at her boarding school.
而且，与利奥波德不同，玛丽有惊人的记忆力。她告诉了我日军到达她寄宿学校的那一天。
The day after Pearl Harbor was attacked, the Japanese showed up on the doorstep of our school. They put seals with Japanese writing on everything-- the tables, the chairs, the pianos, the desks. Everything belonged to the Great Emperor of Japan.
珍珠港遇袭的第二天，日本人出现在我们学校的门口。他们在所有东西上都贴上了带有日文的封条——桌子、椅子、钢琴、书桌。一切都属于日本伟大的天皇。
And then they put arm bands on us. Everyone had to wear an arm band. A for American, B for British, whatever our nationality was.
然后他们给我们戴上了臂章。每个人都必须戴臂章。A代表美国，B代表英国，无论我们的国籍是什么。
The girls were eventually transferred into Weihsien. Mary became a concentration camp Girl Guide. This was over 70 years ago. But when Mary talks about the camp, she sounds like she's still there, like she's 12 years old again.
女孩们最终被转移到了潍县。玛丽成了一名集中营女童军。那已经是70多年前的事了。但当玛丽谈起集中营时，她听起来就像还在那里，就像她又回到了12岁。
She said this story about the Brown Owls insisting on good table manners, absolutely true.
她说关于猫头鹰坚持良好的餐桌礼仪的故事是绝对真实的。
So you're eating some kind of glop out of a maybe boiled animal grain-- because [CHINESE] is a broomcorn that the Chinese feed to their animals-- was often what they fed us. And you're eating it out of a soap dish or a tin can.
所以你在吃某种粘糊糊的东西，来自某种煮沸的动物谷物——因为高粱是中国的扫帚玉米，中国人喂给动物吃的东西——往往就是他们喂给我们的东西。你用肥皂盒或罐头盒盛着吃。
And here comes Miss Stark up behind us-- one of our teachers. "Mary Taylor, do not slouch over your food while you are eating. Do not talk while you have food in your mouth. And there are not two sets of manners, one set of manners for the princesses in Buckingham Palace and another set of manners for the Weihsien concentration camp."
然后斯塔克小姐出现在我们身后——我们的老师之一。“玛丽·泰勒，吃东西时不要弯着腰。嘴里有东西时不要说话。礼仪没有两套，白金汉宫公主的一套礼仪，和潍县集中营的另一套礼仪是不一样的。”
Mary was separated from her parents, unsure of when she'd BE released, surrounded by pack dogs and men with guns. She says that she spent a lot of her time just thinking about earning merit badges.
玛丽与父母分离，不知道何时会被释放，被看门狗和持枪的男人包围。她说她大部分时间都在想赚取功勋徽章。
In the winter, it would get cold, freezing. But no heat was provided to the prisoners by the guards. Instead, Mary and her friends had to go collect leftover coal shavings from the guards' quarters.
冬天，天会变得很冷，结冰。但守卫没有给囚犯提供任何取暖设备。相反，玛丽和她的朋友们必须去收集守卫宿舍剩下的煤渣。
I remember now the ritual of going to Japanese quarters to get the coal dust and carry it back.
我现在还记得去日本营地取煤灰并运回来的仪式。
Like making a new pencil from pencil shavings, except the coal is heavy. And it had to be passed bucket by bucket in a line of Girl Guides. Then the shavings were mixed with dust and water and dried in the sun. It was long, hard work.
就像用铅笔屑制作一支新铅笔，除了煤很重。而且必须一桶接一桶地通过女童军组成的队列传下去。然后煤屑与灰尘和水混合，在太阳下晒干。那是漫长、艰苦的工作。
And then at the end of it, you still had to go use that recycled coal in a pot-bellied stove and keep the stove lit so that everybody would be warm. It sounded horrible, like a childhood from a Charles Dickens novel. Except Mary remembers it as being surprisingly fun, a game she could win.
最后，你还得用那种回收煤，在一个大肚子炉子里把它点燃，并保持炉子一直燃烧，这样大家才会温暖。这听起来很可怕，像查尔斯·狄更斯小说里的童年。但玛丽记得那非常有趣，是一个她能赢的游戏。
I and my partner, Marjorie Harrison, we won the competition in our dormitory of which stove lighting team made the pot-bellied stove in the winter turn red hot more times than any other girl in the camp. Well, you know, here I am, 82 years old, and what do I choose to tell you? I won. The pot-belly turned red more times with me and Marjorie Harrison than any other girl in our dorm.
我和我的伙伴玛乔丽·哈里森（Marjorie Harrison），我们赢得了宿舍里的比赛，比营地里任何其他女孩更多次地把大肚子炉烧得通红。好吧，你知道，我82岁了，我选择告诉你的竟然是这个？我赢了。我和玛乔丽·哈里森让炉子变红的次数比宿舍里任何其他女孩都多。
When you describe it, it sounds like you're describing summer camp instead of describing a concentration camp. Did it feel like summer camp? Did you ever--
当你描述它时，听起来就像你在描述夏令营，而不是描述集中营。感觉像夏令营吗？你有没有——
Well, I never was in a summer camp. So I can't give you a-- no, no, no, absolutely not. When you had guard dogs, bayonet drills, electrified wires, barrier walls, pill boxes with armed guards in them, you weren't in a summer camp. Don't misunderstand me. I'm not saying this was Fun City. I'm telling you, we lived a miracle where grownups preserved our childhood.
嗯，我从来没去过夏令营。所以我不能给你一个——不，不，不，绝对没有。当你拥有警犬、刺刀演习、带电铁丝网、障碍墙、里面有武装警卫的碉堡时，你就不是在夏令营。别误会我。我不是说这是“快乐之城”。我是在告诉你，我们经历了一个奇迹，大人们呵护了我们的童年。
There's reference in the logbook to the trouble the adults were having keeping it together, but you'd have to know to look for it. A scout leader writes one entry that reads, "Dear me, what a tragedy. Brown Owl had an attack of neuralgia. Let's hope he's better for our meeting.
日志中有关于成年人们在维持秩序方面遇到困难的记录，但你得知道怎么找。一位童子军领袖写了一条记录，上面写着：“天哪，真是个悲剧。猫头鹰发作了神经痛。希望他在我们的会议前能好起来。”
Neuralgia's a nerve disorder. But what that actually meant was that the Brown Owl was having a nervous breakdown. Years later, Mary went and tracked down one of the grownups.
神经痛是一种神经系统疾病。但那实际上意味着猫头鹰正在精神崩溃。多年后，玛丽去寻找了其中一位大人。
I said, Miss Carr, what were you feeling when we were in a concentration camp? Well, all the grownups in the camp knew about the rape of Nanking, the atrocities that the soldiers had done when they came to the southern city of Nanking.
我说，卡尔小姐，当我们在集中营时你有什么感觉？好吧，营地里的所有大人们都知道南京大屠杀，士兵们来到南方城市南京时犯下的暴行。
Japanese soldiers went door to door, systematically raping and killing tens of thousands of Chinese civilians.
日本士兵挨家挨户，有系统地强奸和屠杀了数万名中国平民。
So they knew what could happen. The teachers knew what could happen. So I said to Miss Carr, what were you feeling? She said, well, I would pray to God that when they lined us up along the death trenches-- and they were outside the camp-- when they lined us up to shoot us so our bodies would fall into the death pits, that I would be one of the first so I didn't have to see it.
所以他们知道可能发生什么。老师们知道可能发生什么。所以我对卡尔小姐说，你有什么感觉？她说，好吧，我会向神祈祷，当我们被排成一排站在死亡壕沟边——他们在营地外面——当我们被排成一排等待被枪杀，让我们的身体落入死亡深坑时，我希望我是第一个，这样我就不必看到了。
So there were two sets of prayers. At night, the grownups, many of them not much older than the kids themselves, prayed grimly for a fast death. And then they woke up in the morning and they sang songs with the kids, set the bouncy camp melodies.
所以有两套祈祷。晚上，大人们，其中许多人并不比孩子们大多少，严峻地祈祷能死得快一点。然后他们早上醒来，和孩子们一起唱着歌，设定那些轻快的露营旋律。
It was like you weren't going to be afraid if you could sing about it. We would sing, (SINGING) Day is done. Gone the sun from the sea, from the hills, from the sky. All is well, safely rest. God is nigh.
就像如果你能唱出来，你就不会害怕。我们会唱，（歌唱）“白昼结束。太阳隐入海中，隐入山后，隐入天空。一切安好，安息吧。神就在身旁。”
How could you be afraid when you're singing about all is well, safely rest, God is nigh? How could you be afraid of that?
当你唱着一切安好、安息吧、神就在身旁时，你怎么会害怕呢？你怎么会对此感到害怕呢？
So we were constantly putting things into music. Often, you know, there was a little bit of a twist of fun to it. One of the songs that we sang was, (SINGING) We might have been shipped to Timbuktu. We might have been shipped to Kalamazoo. It's not repatriation or isn't yet stagnation. It's only concentration in Chefoo.
所以我们不断地把事情编进音乐里。通常，你知道，里面会有一点点乐趣的转折。我们唱的其中一首歌是，（歌唱）“我们可能被送到了廷巴克图。我们可能被送到了卡拉马祖。这不是遣返，也不是滞留。这仅仅是在芝罘的集中营。”
There probably aren't many places on earth where you have less reason to be cheerful than a concentration camp. But it turns out, in a place like that, being able to be cheerful, to have a positive outlook, it's not dopey or silly. It's how you survive. How you tell the story matters.
地球上可能没有多少地方比集中营更没有理由快乐。但事实证明，在那样的地方，能够快乐，拥有积极的心态，那并不愚蠢或可笑。那是你生存的方式。你讲述故事的方式很重要。
For example, one of the things that we sang when the Japanese were marching us into concentration camp was the first verse of Psalm 46. (SINGING) God is our refuge, our refuge and our strength. And on it goes. In trouble, we will not be afraid.
例如，当日本人把我们强行带进集中营时，我们唱的一首歌是诗篇第46篇的第一节。（歌唱）“神是我们的避难所，我们的力量。等等。在危难中，我们不会惧怕。”
All of these words just sung into our hearts. That sticks. It's like you've got a groove sticking in the gramophone record. I am safe. I am safe. I am safe. That was just profound.
所有这些词都唱进了我们的心里。这会留下来。就像你的唱片机上卡住了一个槽。我是安全的。我是安全的。我是安全的。这真是太深刻了。
The first Chefoo brownies warded off despair for four years, until finally, on August 17, 1945, they were rescued.
第一批芝罘布朗尼队抵挡了四年的绝望，直到最后，在1945年8月17日，她们获救了。
It was a windy day.
那是一个多风的日子。
Mary remembers the American plane flying low over the camp.
玛丽记得美国飞机在营地上空低空飞行。
And the parachutes falling from the sky. All I knew was I was running to find whoever it was that was dropping out of the sky beyond the barrier walls.
降落伞从天而降。我所知道的就是我在奔跑，去寻找那些正在障碍墙外从天而降的人。
I'm there in the hot sun. It's a blue sky. It's a brown slope. It's a browned earth.
我在烈日下。这是蓝天。这是棕色的斜坡。是褐色的土地。
And the people went berserk.
人们都疯了。
People running all over the place.
人们四处奔跑。
People were crying, screaming, dancing.
人们在哭，在尖叫，在跳舞。
Somebody picks me up, and then I wake up.
有人把我抱起来，然后我就醒了。
Leopold says that the nightmare that used to haunt him is just his memory of that day, of being a four-year-old, lost and wandering around a riot of freed concentration camp survivors. Most of the people who are there on liberation day are now dead.
利奥波德说，那个曾经困扰他的噩梦只是他对那一天的记忆，作为一个四岁的孩子，迷失在获释的集中营幸存者的狂欢中。解放那天在场的大多数人现在都已经去世了。
One of the dormitories at Weihsien's a memorial, but mostly this place exists as a footnote in some books on a website designed by a Belgian man and in the memories of the remaining survivors. It's a half disappeared world with a strong pull on the people who do still remember it.
潍县的宿舍之一是一个纪念馆，但这个地方大多作为一个脚注存在于一些书和比利时男子设计的网站上，以及剩余幸存者的记忆中。这是一个半消失的世界，对那些仍然记得它的人有很强的吸引力。
A couple weeks ago at the grocery store, I watched a gang of Brownie Scouts rush down the pet food aisle. They had their uniforms on, covered in merit badges for public speaking and backyard astronomy. They were happy and safe in their own world, a million miles from Weihsien. I wondered if they knew what they might be capable of.
几周前在杂货店，我看着一群布朗尼女童子军冲进宠物食品通道。她们穿着制服，上面布满了公共演讲和后院天文学的功勋徽章。她们在自己的世界里快乐而安全，距离潍县有百万英里之遥。我不知道她们是否知道自己可能具备什么能力。
PJ Vogt. He's the co-host of the podcast "Reply All," where this story came from, and which I am a big fan of. You can subscribe to "Reply All" on iTunes, or wherever you get your podcasts.
PJ·沃格特。他是播客“Reply All”的联合主持人，这个故事就来自那里，我非常喜欢那个节目。你可以在iTunes上，或者任何你获取播客的地方订阅“Reply All”。
On July 28, "Reply All" is going to be appearing in Cast Party, which is a podcast festival broadcast live to movie theaters across the country. It also features "Radiolab" and "Invisibilia." Info and tickets at castparty.org.
7月28日，“Reply All”将出现在Cast Party上，这是一个在全国电影院直播的播客节。它还包括“Radiolab”和“Invisibilia”。信息和门票请访问castparty.org。
Coming up, Aziz Ansari thinks you don't know how to text. And when he makes the case, I have to say, I think you're going to believe him. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，阿兹·安萨里（Aziz Ansari）认为你不知道该怎么发短信。当他提出这个论点时，我必须说，我想你会相信他的。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. We bring you different stories on that theme. Today's show, "Captain's Log," stories where we take the unemotional facts in logs and records of various sorts, and we look behind them at the much more emotional, complicated stories that they are so stoically documenting. We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, "Romancing the Phone."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题。我们会为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“船长日志”，我们在节目中选取 unemotional（无情感）事实的日志和各种记录，然后看看它们背后那些被极其冷静地记录下来的更加情感化、复杂的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕，第二幕，“浪漫电话”。
Recently, my wife and I, we were texting some things to each other that were so intense that at the end she suggested we just delete all of our texts that we had ever written to each other ever. And it wasn't like we thought that anybody else was going to see our texts. It's like we just didn't want them to exist in this world any more.
最近，我和妻子之间发了一些非常激烈的短信，最后她建议我们删除我们之间写过的所有短信。这并不是说我们觉得会有其他人看到我们的短信。这只是说我们不希望它们再存在于这个世界上。
We wanted that history of our conversation to vanish forever from the face of the earth, never think about it again. You know, it's like text messages are this little history. It's like they're our logbook of our interactions with people.
我们希望我们谈话的历史从地球表面永远消失，再也不去想它。你知道，这就像短信是这种小小的历史。就像它们是我们与人互动的日志。
And of course, usually they're not so emotional. Usually they're pretty terse, which totally makes them perfect for today's program, because their terseness behind it, there can be a whole story.
当然，通常它们并不那么情绪化。通常它们相当简练，这让它们非常适合今天的节目，因为它们的简练背后，可能包含着整个故事。
And recently, a sociologist started to study this. This was not very traditional sociology. The sociologist Eric Klinenberg at NYU teamed up with a comedian, Aziz Ansari, to examine the texts that people send to each other right when they start dating. And they put out a book with her findings. It's called Modern Romance .
最近，一位社会学家开始研究这个。这不是非常传统的社会学。纽约大学的社会学家埃里克·克林伯格（Eric Klinenberg）与喜剧演员阿兹·安萨里合作，检查人们刚开始约会时互相发送的短信。并出了一本关于她发现的书。叫《现代浪漫》（Modern Romance）。
And what they did, they spoke to a few hundred people. Their research was conducted in focus groups, like 10 to 20 people in a room, in eight different cities. And then sometimes they would do a version of these focus groups on stage in front of audiences, in New York and Los Angeles.
他们所做的是，他们和几百个人谈过。他们的研究是在焦点小组中进行的，比如一个房间里有10到20个人，在八个不同的城市。有时他们会在纽约和洛杉矶的观众面前进行这些焦点小组的版本。
What they would do is Aziz would get up, and he would do a little stand up. And then he would introduce Eric, like Eric was the next comic who was coming on stage.
他们会做的是阿兹站起来，做一小段脱口秀。然后他会介绍埃里克，就像埃里克是下一个登台的喜剧演员。
Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome Mr. Eric Klinenberg.
女士们，先生们，请欢迎埃里克·克林伯格先生。
So Eric would come up, and he would talk a little bit about previous work that he'd done. And he would drop this statistic, that in 1950, 23% of American adults were single.
所以埃里克会走上来，谈谈他之前所做的工作。他会抛出这个统计数据，在1950年，23%的美国成年人是单身。
And today, about half of all adults are single. About half of all of adults are single. And I live in Manhattan. And in Manhattan, one out of every two households has just one person.
而今天，大约一半的成年人是单身。大约一半的成年人是单身。我住在曼哈顿。在曼哈顿，每两个家庭中就有一个只有一个人。
Several people in the audience go "hmm."
观众中有几个人发出“嗯”的声音。
See, I got a "hmm," Aziz.
看，我得到了一个“嗯”，阿兹。
Those are like big laughs for sociologists, when people are like, "whoo." Gasps. I imagine backstage at sociology conferences, it's just like, man, I got so many gasps.
对于社会学家来说，这些就像巨大的笑声，当人们发出“喔”的声音时。惊叹。我想象在社会学会议的后台，就像是，老兄，我收到了好多惊叹。
Like, did you hear how many gasps there were? You hear how many rumblings there were after I dropped that statistic? Those are good stats, man. Those are great stats.
就像，你听到有多少惊叹了吗？你听到我在抛出那个统计数据后有多少隆隆声了吗？那是好数据，老兄。那是很棒的数据。
Now what Eric and Aziz were interested in was exactly what it is that people say to each other when they want to ask somebody out on a date. So at these shows, Aziz and Eric would ask people for their phones, and then they would take their phones, and they would read their text messages out loud to the crowd.
现在埃里克和阿兹感兴趣的是当人们想约某人出去时，他们到底会对对方说什么。所以在这些节目中，阿兹和埃里克会向人们索要手机，然后他们会拿走手机，并大声向人群读出他们的短信。
Those texts, that log, that was the raw data for their research. And if you think about it from a research perspective, texts are great, because they are a real time record of what actually transpired, which is way more reliable and accurate than asking people later on to recall what happened. One of our producers, Jonathan Manjivar, dove into that data, and he now explains how those shows would go.
那些短信，那份日志，就是他们研究的原始数据。如果你从研究的角度思考，短信很棒，因为它们是实际发生的事情的实时记录，这比事后要求人们回忆发生的事情要可靠和准确得多。我们的制作人之一，乔纳森·曼吉瓦尔（Jonathan Manjivar），深入挖掘了那些数据，他现在解释了那些节目是如何进行的。
A quick warning before he starts, we're talking about dating. So there's nothing explicit in this story at all, but we acknowledge the existence of sex. Now here's Jonathan.
在他开始之前的一个简短警告，我们是在谈论约会。所以这个故事里没有任何露骨的东西，但我们承认性的存在。现在有请乔纳森。
This particular focus groups slash comedy show was recorded at the Upright Citizens Brigade theater in New York. The room had been split up so that all the guys were on one side. The girls were on the other.
这个特定的焦点小组兼喜剧演出是在纽约的“正直公民旅”剧院录制的。房间被分开了，男士们都在一边。女士们在另一边。
And pretty quickly into the show, Aziz asked for volunteers to come up on stage. He and Eric specifically wanted guys who had recently made first contact with a woman they were interested in. How had the guys made their initial approach?
在节目很快开始时，阿兹要求志愿者上台。他和埃里克特别想要那些最近刚与他们感兴趣的女性进行过初次接触的男士。男士们是如何进行最初的接触的？
So four guys get up on stage. And then, one by one, they hand over their phones to Aziz.
所以四名男士上台了。然后，他们一个接一个地把手机交给阿兹。
Pull up your text message exchange with these women. And what we want you to do is scroll to the very first message you sent to the women.
打开你和这些女性的短信记录。我们想让你做的是滚动到你发给这些女性的第一条信息。
Aziz starts reading texts. And the first guy, he'd been set up by his boss, not over text but over email. The email was sent to both him and his potential date. And it just said, "Cocktails, go get some." So this guy emailed the woman.
阿兹开始读短信。第一个家伙，他是被他的老板介绍的，不是通过短信，而是通过邮件。邮件同时发给了他和他的潜在约会对象。上面只写着：“鸡尾酒，去喝一杯。”所以这个家伙给那个女人发了邮件。
You said, "Hey, Jared," that's his boss, "sure has a way of setting things up, dot dot dot, LOL. Would love to get a drink. When is it good for you, early next week or following Thanksgiving? My number is blah blah blah, by the way, if that is an easier way of communicating. And then she texted you, correct?"
你说，“嘿，贾里德，”那是他的老板，“确实有办法安排事情，点点点，大笑。想去喝一杯。你什么时候方便，下周初还是感恩节后？顺便说一句，如果这是更简单的交流方式，我的号码是blablabla。然后她给你发了短信，对吧？”
A week later.
一周后。
A week-- a week later? Everyone's like [BLEEP] that [BLEEP] why'd you do that? So OK, so she said, "Hey, Zach," exclamation. "It's Collette, Jared's friend. I'm so, so sorry. I completely lost track of your email and forgot to respond. But--" no one believes her.
一周——一周后？每个人都像，该死，那，你为什么要那样做？所以，好的，她说，“嘿，扎克，”感叹号。“我是科莱特，贾里德的朋友。我非常非常抱歉。我完全忘记了你的邮件，忘了回复。但是——”没人相信她。
How many people don't believe that she really lost track?
有多少人认为她真的忘了邮件？
No hands go up.
没人举手。
That's insane. There's not one person that believes that someone could lose track of something anymore. OK. So she said, I'm sorry. I lost track of your email and forgot to respond, but I'd love to grab a drink if you're free this week. So she wrote that on Friday at 12:45.
这太疯狂了。没有任何人相信现在有人会忘记某件事。好的。所以她说，对不起。我忘记了你的邮件，没回复，但如果你这周有空，我很乐意去喝一杯。所以她在周五12:45写了那个。
So the guy wrote back.
所以那个家伙回信了。
"Hey, Collette, dot dot dot. Would love to get a drink, dot dot dot. Wednesday works well for me, dot dot dot. How about you?" Question mark. OK.
“嘿，科莱特，点点点。很想去喝一杯，点点点。周三对我来说很方便，点点点。你呢？”问号。好的。
OK, so Aziz moves on to guy number two, because what's about to happen is that we're going to hear all of their initial attempts. And then the women in the audience are going to vote on who did it best. Guy number two met a woman on the train one night.
好的，所以阿兹转向第二个家伙，因为接下来要发生的是我们将听到他们所有的初步尝试。然后观众席中的女性将投票选出谁做得最好。第二个家伙有一天晚上在火车上遇到了一个女人。
The next morning, he sent the message. This is what he said. "Hey, Audrey. This is Joe. Nice meeting you real quick last night. How are you?" Question mark. So that's his first message. And then--
第二天早上，他发了那条信息。这是他说的。“嘿，奥黛丽。我是乔。昨晚很高兴见到你。你好吗？”问号。所以那是他的第一条信息。然后——
Moving on to guy number three, he had met a woman at an NYU alumni event.
继续第三个家伙，他在纽约大学校友活动上遇到了一个女人。
And then you wrote a message a few days later. And this is two messages, OK. You said, "Hey there. How'd your Thanksgiving feast turn out?" Question mark. "Here's a shot of the spread I put together. I'd say it came out all right." Smiley face. "Yo. I know it's tiny, but I promise, it looks delicious."
然后你几天后写了一条信息。这是两条信息，好的。你说，“嘿，你好。感恩节大餐怎么样？”问号。“这是我做的菜的照片。”笑脸。“哟。我知道它很小，但我保证，它看起来很美味。”
Guy number four got someone's number at a wedding. She left the wedding. And then not long after, he texted her.
第四个家伙在婚礼上得到了某人的号码。她离开了婚礼。没过多久，他就给她发了短信。
Was this like a "hey, this is my number" type text? OK. So you say, "What's up? It's Theo." That's the voice your text has.
这是像“嘿，这是我的号码”那样的短信吗？好的。所以你说，“怎么了？我是西奥。”那是你的短信语音。
And then she said, "Hey, nothing much. Hey, NM. Just heading back home. How's the party going?" And then you set a few minutes later, "It's fun. You left too early. Ha ha. This was like [BLEEP]. I thought we were boning tonight."
然后她说，“嘿，没啥。嘿，NM。刚回家。派对怎么样？”然后你几分钟后设置，“这很有趣。你走得太早了。哈哈。这就像该死。我还以为我们今晚会做爱。”
Was that, like, what you were really thinking. Like, you know, we could have just-- so then, the next night, you send her the equivalent of your first contact, if you will. And you say, "It was cool meeting you last night. I'll be back in Cali in two weeks for winter break. We should hang out some time. Ha ha." It wasn't necessarily a Young Jeezy ha ha. It was just a ha ha.
那是你真正在想的吗？就像，你知道，我们本来可以——所以然后，第二天晚上，你给她发了你第一次接触的等价物，如果你愿意的话。你说，“昨晚见到你很酷。我两周后回加州过寒假。我们要不要找时间聚聚。哈哈。”这不一定是那种很酷的哈哈。这只是一个哈哈。
So four guys, which one did this best? Aziz and Eric turn to the women in the audience.
所以四个家伙，哪一个做得最好？阿兹和埃里克转向观众中的女性。
Why don't we see which one do you guys like the most? Just the women in the audience. Clap if your favorite is this.
我们为什么不看看你们最喜欢哪一个？只是观众席里的女性。如果这是你的最爱，请鼓掌。
So the clear winner, the guy who wrote about Thanksgiving. "Hey there. How'd your Thanksgiving feast turn out? Here's a shot of the spread I put together."
所以明显的赢家是写感恩节的那个家伙。“嘿，你好。感恩节大餐怎么样？这是我做的菜的照片。”
But could we find out from someone here what is so good about that text? If you voted for that text--
但我们能从这里的人那里找出那条短信好在哪里吗？如果你给那条短信投票——
Yeah, raise your hand.
是的，举手。
A woman in the audience, who's a little off mic, says it gets the conversation going. You asked a question. And he said something about his Thanksgiving, and it made you want to comment on it.
观众中的一位女士，稍微离开麦克风，说这能让谈话进行下去。你问了一个问题。他说了关于他的感恩节的事情，让你想评论它。
OK. Anybody else?
好的。还有其他人吗？
It was personal, another woman says. He remembered what you talked about.
它很私人，另一位女士说。他记得你们谈论过什么。
Personal, remember what you talked about.
私人，记得你们谈论过什么。
You guys taking notes over there, by the way? Same time, we kind of need to know what didn't work out so well with the texts that nobody voted for.
顺便问一下，你们在做笔记吗？同时，我们需要知道那些没人投票的短信到底哪里出了问题。
What did you not like about--
你不喜欢什么——
Oh, yeah, all the way in the back.
哦，是的，一直在后面。
The woman in the back doesn't like the "what's up" guy who met someone at a wedding and texted her after she left. In fact, no one liked that text. It got zero claps.
后面的女士不喜欢那个在婚礼上遇到某人并让她离开后发短信的“怎么了”家伙。事实上，没人喜欢那条短信。它得了零次鼓掌。
The woman says, it sounded like he just wanted to have sex. He's saying, I don't live here. But I'm going to be back. Let's hang out. And I don't want to talk to you until then.
这位女士说，听起来他只是想发生关系。他在说，我不住在这里。但我会回来的。让我们聚聚吧。而且我不想在那之前和你说话。
What do you mean? Why do you think he doesn't want to talk to her until then?
你是什么意思？为什么你认为在那之前他不想和她说话？
Because he would have asked a question.
因为他会问一个问题。
He would have asked a question. Does anyone else feel like that?
他会问一个问题。还有其他人感觉那样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Guys are like, must ask questions.
男士们就像，必须问问题。
Other than asking questions, Aziz and Eric have some very clear advice about the kinds of texts their research shows works when you're trying to ask someone out. Number one, invite the person to something specific at a specific time.
除了问问题，阿兹和埃里克对于他们的研究表明当你试图约某人出去时什么样的短信行得通有一些非常明确的建议。第一，邀请对方在特定时间参加特定活动。
Two, say something that refers back to an earlier conversation you had, so it's clear you were listening. And three, say something funny.
第二，说一些指回你们之前对话内容的话，这样很清楚你在听。第三，说一些有趣的话。
Aziz and Eric say most guys, surprisingly, do not instinctually get this. They don't do it. But after dropping this knowledge at the show, women were invited to come up on stage to share texts they'd gotten from guys. And coincidentally, the very first woman received a text from a guy that followed two of the three rules.
阿兹和埃里克说大多数男士，令人惊讶的是，不会本能地理解这一点。他们不这样做。但在演出中抛出这些知识后，女性被邀请上台分享她们从男士那里收到的短信。巧合的是，第一位女性收到了一位遵循三条规则中两条的男士的短信。
This was his first text to you. "Hey, how was the rest of your Thanksgiving?" Question mark. "You want to grab a drink tomorrow around 7:30 in LES?" Question mark. That's a pretty-- whoa.
这是他给你发的第一条短信。“嘿，感恩节剩下的部分怎么样？”问号。“你想明天7:30在LES喝一杯吗？”问号。那是一个相当——哇。
He's good.
他很棒。
She just said, he's good. That's the bar for he's good. "How was your Thanksgiving? Do you want to get a drink Wednesday?" Oh my god. Who is this god?
她只是说，他很棒。这就是他很棒的标准。“感恩节怎么样？你想周三去喝一杯吗？”我的天哪。这个神是谁？
That guy got a date. Another woman got a text that was at the opposite end of the spectrum. The guy pretty much does everything wrong, from the start.
那个家伙约到了。另一位女士收到的短信正好相反。那个家伙从一开始几乎做错了所有事。
OK. So his first message, "Hi." And then you have to go, "Hi, is this Connor?" I mean, this dude doesn't even want to tell his name. "Hey."
好的。所以他的第一条信息，“嗨”。然后你不得不说，“嗨，这是康纳吗？”我是说，这个家伙甚至不想说他的名字。“嘿”。
You said, "Hi. Is this Connor?" And he goes, "This is." Connor, you want to say some [BLEEP]?
你说，“嗨。这是康纳吗？”他说，“这是。”康纳，你想说些该死的东西吗？
"Hi. What's going on?" "I'm actually just waking up. Picking my mix up for my morning. So far, it's consisting of "Goodbye Horses" and "Big Pimping." And you're still being very nice.
“嗨。发生了什么？”“我其实刚醒。正在为我的早晨挑选混合曲。到目前为止，它包括《Goodbye Horses》和《Big Pimping》。”而且你仍然非常有礼貌。
"Oh, nice. Well, what are you up to tonight?" "Tonight, I'm not sure. I may want to eat some mushrooms."
“哦，不错。好吧，你今晚打算做什么？”“今晚，我不确定。我可能想吃些蘑菇。”
No one is like, yeah, you should go out with this guy. Everyone's like, good decision. Way to go.
没人会说，是的，你应该和这个家伙出去。每个人都在说，好决定。做得好。
OK, so to review, there are three rules. Ask a question. Make a specific plan. Be funny.
好的，所以回顾一下，有三条规则。问一个问题。制定一个具体的计划。有趣点。
In fact, this night at the UCB theater, Aziz asked guys in the crowd to text someone they were interested in, right now, armed with this new knowledge. And just before the end of the show--
事实上，在UCB剧院的这一晚，阿兹让台下的男士们给他们感兴趣的人发短信，就在现在，带着这些新知识。就在演出结束前——
Did any of you guys get a message back? Anybody?
你们有人收到回复吗？有人吗？
Oh, come on.
哦，来吧。
You did? OK. Oh my god. OK. OK, so you said, "Hey, I'm finally free from the horrors of math. Do you want to check out a new bar on Franklin next week?" Question mark.
你收到了？好的。我的天哪。好的。好的，所以你说，“嘿，我终于从数学的恐怖中解脱出来了。你下周想去富兰克林街的新酒吧看看吗？”问号。
She wrote back, six minutes later, "Yeah, for sure!" Exclamation. "I'm down. Also, next Thursday is my birthday. So I'm hoping to party it up next weekend." Smiley face. Holy [BLEEP]. We were right.
她回复说，六分钟后，“是的，当然！”感叹号。“我同意。另外，下周四是我的生日。所以我希望下周末能开派对。”笑脸。该死。我们是对的。
Thank you, guys, so much for coming out. We really appreciate it.
非常感谢大家的到来。我们真的很感激。
Aziz Ansari. The book that he wrote with Eric Klinenberg is called Modern Romance . Jonathan Menjivar is one of the producers of our show.
阿兹·安萨里。他和埃里克·克林伯格写的书叫《现代浪漫》。乔纳森·曼吉瓦尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, "On A Quiet Street in Richmond." So all through this hour today, we have documents that describe big dramatic things in the most "just the facts, ma'am" language possible, like a captain's log usually does. And we found this article from 1853 that's a good example of this.
第三幕，“里士满宁静的街道上”。所以今天在这一个小时里，我们有描述巨大戏剧性事件的文档，使用了尽可能“只是事实，女士”的语言，就像船长日志通常那样。我们发现了1853年的这篇文章，就是一个很好的例子。
In the article, a writer named William Chambers went out to witness and report on slave auctions. Apparently enough people had written about these in a very melodramatic and sensationalistic way that Chambers felt like somebody needed to go out and give a true, factual account.
在文章中，一位名叫威廉·钱伯斯（William Chambers）的作家去观察和报道奴隶拍卖。显然，已经有足够多的人以非常戏剧化和耸人听闻的方式写过这些事情，钱伯斯觉得需要有人出去提供真实、客观的记录。
Everything is described precisely as it occurred, without passion or prejudice. It would not have been difficult to be sentimental on a subject which appeals so strongly to the feelings but I preferred telling the simple truth.
一切都精确地描述了发生的事情，没有激情或偏见。在处理一个如此强烈地诉诸情感的主题时，表现得感伤并不困难，但我更喜欢说出简单的事实。
Our excerpts of Chambers' article were read for us by actor John Ellison Conlee. By 1853, slavery was controversial, and Chambers opposed it. He was a Scottish guy, an outsider.
钱伯斯文章的节选是由演员约翰·埃里森·康利（John Ellison Conlee）为我们朗读的。到1853年，奴隶制是一个有争议的问题，钱伯斯反对它。他是个苏格兰人，局外人。
And so he spent a couple days going from one auction shop to another in Richmond, Virginia. Chambers explains that he's seen advertisements for slave sales. And when he went to the addresses, he found a narrow short street between two main streets in the city, brick houses on either side where there were a few small auction shops.
所以他花了几周时间从里士满的一家拍卖行走到另一家。钱伯斯解释说他看过奴隶销售的广告。当他走到这些地址时，他发现两大街之间的狭窄街道，两边是砖房，那里有几家小型拍卖行。
On this particular day, it was pretty empty. Shops were identifiable by little red flags that hung outside their doors. And pinned to each flag was a piece of paper listing the men, women, and children who were going to be sold that day.
在这一天，这里相当空旷。店铺可以通过门外悬挂的小红旗来识别。每一面旗子上都钉着一张纸，列出了那天要被卖掉的男人、女人和孩子。
Conceive the idea of a large shop with two windows and a door between, no shelving or counters inside, the interior a spacious, dismal apartment, not well swept. The only furniture a desk at one of the windows and a bench at one side of the shop, three feet high with two steps to it from the floor.
设想一下一家大店，两个窗户，中间有一扇门，里面没有架子或柜台，内部是一个宽敞、阴郁的公寓，没有扫干净。唯一的家具是窗户边的一张桌子和店边上的一张长凳，高三英尺，有两级台阶从地面通向它。
Conceive the idea of this dismal looking place with nobody in it but three Negro children who, as I entered, were playing at auctioneering each other. An intensely black little Negro of four or five years of age was standing on the bench-- or block, as it is called-- with an equally black girl, about a year younger, by his side whom he was pretending to sell by bids to another black child who was rolling about the floor.
设想一下这个阴郁的地方，除了三个黑人孩子外一个人也没有，我进去时，他们正在玩拍卖对方的游戏。一个四五岁、黑得发亮的黑人小男孩站在长凳——或者叫拍卖台——上，身边站着一个大约小一岁、同样黑的女孩，他假装要把她卖给另一个在地上滚来滚去的黑人孩子。
My appearance did not interrupt the merriment. The little auctioneer continued his play and appeared to enjoy the joke of selling the girl who stood demurely by his side. "$50 for the girl. $50, $50. I sell this here fine girl for $50," was uttered, with appropriate gestures in imitation, doubtless, of the scenes he had seen and acted daily on the spot.
我的出现并没有打断欢乐。小拍卖官继续他的游戏，似乎很享受卖掉那个羞怯地站在他身边的女孩的笑话。“50美元买这个女孩。50美元，50美元。我把这个好女孩卖50美元，”他带着适当的手势模仿说，毫无疑问，模仿的是他每天在现场看到和演出的场景。
I spoke a few words but was scarcely understood. And the fun went on as if I had not been present. So I left them, happy and rehearsing what was likely soon to be their own fate.
我说了几句话，但几乎没人听懂。游戏继续进行，仿佛我根本没在场一样。所以我离开了他们，快乐地排练着他们自己很快就会面临的命运。
At 9:30 AM, at another store, Chambers is approached by a salesman and asked if he's there to buy a slave. Chambers explains that he is not. He's simply there to witness the sales and gather information, which seems fine with the salesman. A lanky man sits down next to Chambers wearing what Chambers calls a wide awake hat, which is a hat with a kind of low round crown and a wide brim.
上午9:30，在另一家店，一名推销员走近钱伯斯，问他是否是来买奴隶的。钱伯斯解释说他不是。他只是来见证销售并收集信息的，这在推销员看来没什么问题。一个瘦长的男人坐在钱伯斯旁边，戴着钱伯斯所谓的“清醒帽”，那是一种带有某种低圆顶和宽帽檐的帽子。
Looking towards the door, I observe the subjects of sale. The man and boy indicated by the paper on the red flag enter together, whence, as the day was chilly, they edge themselves towards the fire in the corner where I was seated. I was now between the two parties, the white man on the right and the old and young Negro on the left. And I waited to see what would take place.
看向门外，我观察到销售对象。纸上和红旗上指出的男人和男孩一起进入，因为天气寒冷，他们向角落里的火炉边挤去。我现在处于双方之间，右边是白人，左边是老黑人和小黑人。我等着看会发生什么。
The sight of the Negroes at once attracted the attention of Wide Awake. He kept keenly eyeing the pair as if to see what they were good for. Under this searched gaze, the man and boy were a little abashed but said nothing.
黑人的视线立刻吸引了“清醒”的注意。他一直敏锐地注视着这对父子，仿佛在看他们有什么用。在这种搜索的注视下，男人和男孩有点窘迫，但什么也没说。
Their appearance had little of the repulsiveness we are apt to associate with the idea of slaves. They were dressed in a grey woolen coat, pants, and waistcoat, colored cotton neck cloths, clean shirts, coarse woolen stockings, and stout shoes.
他们的外表几乎没有我们习惯于与奴隶想法联系在一起的排斥感。他们穿着灰色的羊毛外套、裤子和背心，彩色的棉质颈巾，干净的衬衫，粗羊毛袜和结实的鞋子。
Moved by a sudden impulse, Wide Awake left his seat and, rounding the back of my chair, began to grasp at the man's arms, as if to feel their muscular capacity. He then examined his hands and fingers, and last of all told him to open his mouth and show his teeth, which he did in a submissive manner.
被一种突然的冲动所驱使，“清醒”离开了座位，绕过我的椅背，开始抓住男人的手臂，仿佛要感受他们的肌肉能力。然后他检查了他的手和手指，最后告诉他张开嘴并展示他的牙齿，他以顺从的方式做了。
Having finished these examinations, Wide Awake resumed his seat. I asked the elder Negro what was his age. He said he did not know. I next inquired how old the boy was. He said he was seven years of age.
检查完毕，“清醒”回到了座位。我问那个年长的黑人他的年龄。他说他不知道。我接着问男孩几岁了。他说他七岁。
On asking the man if the boy was his son, he said he was not. He was his cousin.
当我问那个男人男孩是否是他的儿子时，他说不是。他是他的表弟。
Chambers and the man that he calls Wide Awake wait around for a while for the auction to start and then get tired of waiting. And they leave the shop to check out another one further up the street.
钱伯斯和那个他称为“清醒”的人在那里等了一会儿拍卖开始，然后等得不耐烦了。他们离开了商店，去检查街道上方的另一家。
Here, according to the announcement on the paper stuck to the flag, there were to be sold a woman and three children, a young woman, three men, a middle aged woman, and a little boy. Already a crowd had met. A few were seated near a fire on the right-hand side, and others stood around an iron stove in the middle of the apartment. The whole place had a dilapidated appearance.
这里，根据旗子上贴的纸上的公告，要卖的是一个女人和三个孩子，一个年轻女人，三个男人，一个中年女人和一个小男孩。人群已经聚集了。少数人坐在右侧火炉附近，其他人站在公寓中间的铁炉旁。整个地方看起来破败不堪。
From a back window, there was a view into a ruinous courtyard, beyond which, in a hollow, accessible by a side lane, stood a shabby brick house on which the word jail was inscribed in large black letters on a white ground. I imagined it to be a depot for the reception of Negroes.
从后面的窗户，可以看到一个破败的院子，在那个院子下面，通过一条侧巷，矗立着一栋破旧的砖房，上面用大的黑色字母在白色的地面上刻着“监狱”这个词。我以为这是接收黑人的仓库。
On my arrival, and while making these preliminary observations, the lots for sale had not made their appearance. In about five minutes afterwards, they were ushered in, one after the other, under the charge of a mulatto, who seemed to act as a principal assistant.
当我到达时，在做这些初步观察的同时，要出售的货物还没有出现。大约五分钟后，在一个看起来像主要助手的混血儿的带领下，他们被一个接一个地迎了进来。
I saw no whips, chains, or any other engine of force, nor did such appear to be required. All the lots took their seats on two long forms near the stove. None showed any signs of resistance, nor did anyone utter a word. Their manner was that of perfect humility and resignation.
我没有看到鞭子、锁链或任何其他武力引擎，似乎也不需要。所有的货物都坐在火炉附近的两个长凳上。没有一个人表现出任何抵抗的迹象，也没有一个人说一句话。他们的态度是完美的谦逊和顺从。
As soon as all were seated, there was a general examination of their respective merits by feeling their arms, looking into their mouths. Yet there was no abrupt rudeness in making these examinations, no coarse or domineering language was employed. The three Negro men were dressed in the usual manner, in grey woolen clothing.
一旦所有人都坐下，便开始了通过触摸手臂、看向嘴里来普遍检查他们各自的优点。但这些检查中没有突兀的粗鲁，也没有使用粗鲁或专横的语言。三个黑人男人穿着通常的方式，穿着灰色羊毛衣服。
The woman with three children excited my peculiar attention. She was neatly attired with a colored handkerchief bound around her head and wore a white apron over her gown. Her children were all girls, one of them a baby at the breast three months old, and the others two and three years of age, respectively, rigged out with clean white pinafores.
那个带着三个孩子的女人引起了我特别的关注。她穿着整齐，头上扎着彩色手帕，长袍外面系着白色围裙。她的孩子都是女孩，其中一个是三个月大的吃奶婴儿，另外两个分别是两岁和三岁，穿着干净的白色围兜。
There was not a tear or an emotion visible in the whole party. Everything seemed to be considered as a matter of course. And the change of owners was possibly looked forward to do with as much indifference as ordinary hired servants anticipate a removal from one employer to another.
整个队伍里没有一丝眼泪或情绪。一切似乎都被认为是理所当然的。所有者变更可能被视为像普通雇佣仆人预期从一个雇主换到另一个雇主一样无所谓。
While intending purchasers were proceeding with personal examinations of the several lots, I took the liberty of putting a few questions to the mother of the children. The following was our conversation.
当潜在买家在进行对各种货物的个人检查时，我冒昧地问了孩子们母亲几个问题。以下是我们的对话。
Are you a married woman? Yes, sir. How many children have you had? Seven. Where is your husband? In Madison County.
你是已婚妇女吗？是的，先生。你有几个孩子？七个。你丈夫在哪里？在麦迪逊县。
When did you part from him? On Wednesday, two days ago. Where you sorry to part from him? Yes, sir, she replied with a deep sigh. My heart was almost broke.
你什么时候离开他的？周三，两天前。你很难过离开他吗？是的，先生，她深深地叹了口气回答道。我的心都要碎了。
Why is your master selling you? I don't know. He wants money to buy some land. Suppose he sells me for that.
你主人为什么要卖你？我不知道。他想要钱去买些土地。假设他为了那个卖了我。
There might not be a word of truth in these answers, for I had no means of testing their correctness. But the woman seemed to speak unreservedly. And I am inclined to think that she said nothing but what, if necessary, could be substantiated.
这些回答可能一点真实成分都没有，因为我没有办法测试它们的准确性。但这个女人似乎毫无保留地说话。我倾向于认为除了在必要时能被证实的东西外，她什么也没说。
When the woman and her three children are put up on the auction block, bidding starts at $850. But it only gets up to $890. That won't do, gentleman, the auctioneer says. I cannot take such a low price. And the women and her children step down from the block.
当那个女人和她的三个孩子被放在拍卖台上时，竞标从850美元开始。但它只上升到890美元。那不行，先生们，拍卖商说。我不能接受这么低的价格。那个女人和她的孩子从台上走下来。
$890 is the equivalent of nearly $26,000 today. Chambers reprints a price list. That's what one adult would sell for, not an adult and three kids.
890美元相当于今天的近26,000美元。钱伯斯重印了一份价格表。那是卖掉一个成年人的价格，不是一个成年人和三个孩子。
The most interesting passage in Chambers' report is where he speculates about what the slaves feel about all this. Then in this passage he starts fine.
钱伯斯报告中最有趣的一段是他推测奴隶们对此有什么感觉。然后在这段中他开始做得不错。
There was an entire absence of emotion in the looks of men, women, and children thus seated, preparatory to being sold. This does not correspond with the ordinary accounts of slave sales which are represented as tearful and harrowing.
在那些坐在那里准备被出售的男人、女人的脸上完全没有情绪。这与通常描述的代表泪流满面和令人心碎的奴隶销售的描述不符。
And then, Chambers takes a turn. He says something that is really hard to imagine somebody today writing.
然后，钱伯斯转了一个弯。他说了一些真的很难想象今天的人会写的东西。
My belief is that none of the parties felt deeply on the subject, or at least that any distress they experienced was but momentary, soon passed away and was forgotten. One of my reasons for this opinion rests on a trifling incident which occurred.
我的信念是，没有人对这个主题有深刻的感受，或者至少他们所经历的任何痛苦都只是片刻的，很快就过去了并被遗忘了。我持此观点的理由之一是发生的一个琐碎事件。
While waiting for the commencement of the sale, one of the gentleman present amused himself with a pointer dog which, at command, stood on its hind legs and took pieces of bread from his pocket. These tricks greatly entertained the row of Negroes, old and young. And the poor woman, whose heart three minutes before was almost broken, now laughed as heartily as anyone.
在等待拍卖开始时，在场的一位绅士用一只指示犬逗乐自己，那只狗在命令下用后腿站立，从他口袋里拿面包片。这些把戏极大地娱乐了那些老老少少的黑人队伍。那个三分钟前心几乎碎掉的可怜女人，现在笑得和任何人一样大声。
Today, this just seems wrong-headed. Of course you could be deeply affected by something you're going through and still, you know, laugh at a dog doing tricks. Of course, any of us could contain both those things at the same time. It's weird that Chambers doesn't see that.
今天，这看起来只是思路错误。当然，你可能对你正在经历的事情深深影响，同时，你知道，笑着看狗表演把戏。当然，我们任何人都可能同时包含这两样东西。钱伯斯没看到这一点很奇怪。
A scholar who's written about Chambers told me that Chambers was actually not a keen observer of people in his writing. He doesn't do much character observation when he writes. So it's possible he just was not super perceptive about people's feelings.
一位写过钱伯斯的学者告诉我，钱伯斯在写作中实际上不是一个敏锐的观察者。当他写作时，他没有做太多性格观察。所以很可能他只是对人的感受不是很敏锐。
But also, when you read more of Chambers, it's clear he thinks that white people are superior to black people. He wrote, quote, "A black man is only a kind of man. He stands upright on two legs, his hands to work, wears clothes, can cook his food, a point not reached by monkeys," Chambers writes. "Perhaps," Chambers says, "there's something wrong with his craniological development," which, I guess he means, not as smart.
但同样，当你读更多钱伯斯的著作时，很清楚他认为白人比黑人优越。他写道，引用，“黑人只是一种人。他双腿直立，手工作，穿衣服，能煮食物，这是猴子未达到的点，”钱伯斯写道。“也许，”钱伯斯说，“他的颅骨发育有问题，”我想他的意思是不那么聪明。
So he went on a mission to document the reality of slavery for his readers. He was that enlightened. He was that against it. But that was as far as he went. On his visit to Richmond, he was not able to see the people in front of him for what they really were, which was, of course, exactly the same as him.
所以他带着记录奴隶制现实的任务为他的读者而去。他就是那么开明。他就是那么反对它。但那就是他走的全部路程。在他访问里士满时，他没能看到他面前的人真正是什么，当然，和他是完全一样的。
Act Four, "A Brief History of Us." So to close today's show, we asked a fiction writer, Etgar Keret, to create a short story that works like a captain's log that's told completely through a series of unemotional facts. Here's what he wrote. It's read for us by actress Sue Scott.
第四幕，“我们简史”。为了结束今天的节目，我们要求一位小说家埃特加·克雷特（Etgar Keret），创作一个像船长日志一样工作的短篇故事，完全通过一系列无情感的事实来叙述。这是他写的。由女演员苏·斯科特（Sue Scott）为我们朗读。
At first, we were a cell, then an amoeba, than a fish. And after a very long and frustrating era, we became a lizard. That was the era when, as we recall, the earth felt soft and unsteady beneath our feet. So we climbed a tree.
起初，我们是一个细胞，然后是一个变形虫，然后是一条鱼。在一个非常长且令人沮丧的时代之后，我们成了一只蜥蜴。那是我们记得地球在脚下感觉柔软和不稳定的时代。所以我们爬上了一棵树。
Up there in the treetops, we felt secure. At some point, we climbed down and started walking upright and speaking. And as soon as we began speaking, we just couldn't stop.
在树顶上，我们感到安全。在某个时候，我们爬了下来，开始直立行走并说话。一旦我们开始说话，我们就再也停不下来了。
After that, we watched a lot of TV. It was a fantastic era. We always laughed in the wrong places. And people stared and said, what's so funny? And we didn't even bother answering. That's how little we cared.
在那之后，我们看了很多电视。那是一个奇妙的时代。我们总是在错误的地方大笑。人们盯着看并说，有什么好笑的？我们甚至懒得回答。我们就是这样一点也不在乎。
We promised ourselves we'd find a job we loved. And when that didn't work out, we settled for a job we didn't hate. And we felt lucky, and then unlucky, and then lucky again.
我们答应自己会找到一份我们热爱的工作。当那没成功时，我们满足于一份我们不讨厌的工作。我们感到幸运，然后倒霉，然后又幸运了。
And suddenly, our parents were dying. Then they died. A second before they departed, we held their hand really tight and told him we forgave them for everything-- everything. And our voice broke when we said that, because we weren't convinced we were telling the truth. And we were afraid they could sense it.
突然，我们的父母要死了。然后他们死了。在他们离去前一秒，我们紧紧抓住他们的手，告诉他们我们原谅了他们所做的一切——一切。当我们说那句话时，我们的声音颤抖了，因为我们不相信我们说的是真话。我们害怕他们能感觉到。
Less than a year after that, our son was born. And he also climbed a tree and felt secure up there. And he came down at some point, too, and went off to college. Then we were left alone, and it started getting cold, not like the other time eons ago when we hid in boroughs and peered out while the dinosaurs froze to death, but still depressingly cold.
那之后不到一年，我们的儿子出生了。他也爬上了一棵树，并在上面感到安全。他也爬了下来，去上大学了。然后我们被留下来孤身一人，天气开始变冷，不像几亿年前我们躲在洞穴里偷窥恐龙冷死时的那样，但仍然令人沮丧地冷。
So we went to a drama workshop, because our friend said it would do us good. They gave us a series of improv exercises. And in the first one, we poisoned each other. And in the second one, we cheated on each other.
所以我们去了一个戏剧工作室，因为我们的朋友说这会对我们有好处。他们给我们一系列即兴练习。在第一个练习中，我们互相毒害。在第二个中，我们互相欺骗。
And in the third one, the instructor, who spoke English with a heavy indistinct accent said, now switch partners. And within seconds, it wasn't us anymore.
在第三个中，那个用沉重、模糊口音说英语的教练说，现在交换伙伴。在几秒钟内，这就不是我们了。
The new man who was my partner said, let's do a sketch where you're a baby, and I give birth to you and nurse you and protect you from all evil. And I said, sure, why not? But by the time he'd finished giving birth to me and nursing me and protecting me from all evil, our time was up.
我的伙伴新男人说，让我们演一个素描，你是一个婴儿，我生下你，哺育你，保护你免受一切邪恶。我说，当然，为什么不？但在他生下我、哺育我并保护我免受一切邪恶之后，我们的时间到了。
And the instructor with a strange accent asked if the exercise had made any primal memory surface. And I said it hadn't, because I didn't want to admit that it had brought back warm primordial memories from millions of years ago, from before we even emerged from the water.
带有奇怪口音的教练问练习是否让任何原始记忆浮现。我说没有，因为我不想承认它带回了数百万年前，在我们从水中浮出之前那些温暖的原始记忆。
Afterwards at home, we got into an argument over something really dumb and had the biggest fight we'd ever had since we were created. We yelled and cried and broke things, the kind of things that if you'd asked us a day earlier we'd have told you were unbreakable.
之后在家里，我们因为一些非常愚蠢的事情争吵，并进行了我们自诞生以来最大的一场架。我们大喊大叫，哭了并打碎了东西，如果你早一天问我们，我们肯定会告诉你这些东西是不可打碎的那种。
Then we packed our stuff up in a suitcase and shoved whatever didn't fit in the suitcase into plastic grocery bags. And we dragged all that behind us like homeless people to the apartment where a very wealthy friend of ours lived. And he put a sheet out on his plush sofa for us.
然后我们将东西打包在行李箱里，把塞不进行李箱的东西塞进塑料杂货袋里。我们像流浪汉一样把所有东西拖到我们一位非常富有的朋友居住的公寓里。他在他豪华的沙发上为我们铺了一张床单。
The friend told us that it might seem like the end of the world now. But by morning, all the rage and hurt feelings would melt away, and everything would look different. And we said, no, something had been broken. Something had been torn apart, something we would never be able to mend or forgive.
朋友告诉我们现在世界末日看起来可能到了。但到了早上，所有的愤怒和受伤的感情都会融化，一切看起来都会不一样。我们说，不，有什么东西被打破了。有什么东西被撕裂了，我们永远无法修复或原谅的东西。
The friend lit an imported Slims cigarette and said, OK, maybe so. But can I just ask, why do you keep talking in the plural? Instead of answering, I just looked around and realized I was alone-- truly, completely alone.
朋友点燃了一支进口Slims香烟说，好的，也许是这样。但我能问一下吗，为什么你们一直用复数谈话？没有回答，我只是环顾四周，意识到我是一个人——真正地、彻底地一个人。
Sue Scott, reading a story by Etgar Keret. Etgar's latest book is a memoir called The Seven Good Years . His story was translated from Hebrew by Jessica [INAUDIBLE].
苏·斯科特，朗读埃特加·克雷特的故事。埃特加的最新书是一本叫《七个好年头》（The Seven Good Years）的回忆录。他的故事由杰西卡翻译自希伯来语。
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and myself with Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）和我自己制作，还有肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·曼吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞门（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。
Editing help from Joel Lovell. Production help from Simon Adler, Seth Lind, our operations director, Emily Condon, who's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show.
乔尔·洛弗尔（Joel Lovell）的编辑帮助。西蒙·阿德勒（Simon Adler）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）的制作帮助，我们的运营总监艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）为我们的节目搜寻故事。
Research help today from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天来自米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）的研究帮助。来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[感谢词]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he donated blood this week. And when it was all over, I don't know. He told me he was really feeling out of sorts.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他这周捐了血。当一切结束后，我不知道。他告诉我他真的感到不舒服。
I said, "What's the status on the cookies? Yarr. Me so hungry."
我说，“饼干的情况怎么样了？呀。我好饿。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。